[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the director
of the demos think tank polly mckenzie
and the deputy editor of conservative
home henry hill and they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the times reports that conservative mp
neil parish who today was named as the
politician who viewed pornography on his
phone in the house of commons is being
urged to resign by colleagues he claims
he opened a link by
accident the telegraph has word of mr
parish's refusal to quit
while the guardian says that he now
faces an inquiry by the parliamentary
standards watchdog
the eye has spoken to the staff member
who a parliamentary inquiry found was
bullied by the labour mp liam byrne
he insists that victims of mp's bad
behavior are too scared to report them
the mail understands that tory ministers
are urging police in durham to
re-examine allegations that the labour
leader shakir stammer and his deputy
angela rainer socialized and drank
together in breach of covid regulations
last year
the mirror leads with the prison
sentence handed to legendary tennis
champion boris becker today after he was
found guilty of concealing his assets to
avoid paying off his debts
that story is also on the front of the
sun
the financial times hears that hsbc is
under pressure to split its asian and
western business operations
and reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and tonight we're joined by polly
mckenzie and henry hill welcome to you
both good to see you let's start with
the times and uh neil parish pictured on
the front of the times there and also
with with the story that uh tori's uh
his tory peers are telling him to go
henry
yeah i mean it's not remotely surprising
that conservative mps would dearly like
this man to resign given that this story
has broken uh merely a week before the
local elections in which the
conservative party is already expecting
i think to take quite punishing losses
and local authorities all over the
country now his line is that he has
referred himself to the parliamentary
commissioner for standards he says that
if she finds him guilty he will resign
but he is insisting that that process
must be allowed to take his course and
that in the meantime he will continue to
to perform his duties as member of
parliament now
as a sort of a matter of hr that does
seem reasonable you know these processes
are in place he has the right to avail
himself of them as much as anybody else
but from from a political perspective it
would definitely be sort of much easier
for the party if he uh bit the bullet
what say you polly
well it's an extremely distressing story
that's been running for a couple of days
i'm glad that neil parish has come
forward
and admitted that he is the mp
about whom this allegation was made
because there was a danger that if it
continued to run on all of that
speculation and the sense that basically
all mps were being kind of tarred with
this sense of
of toxic
um
sexual abuse so it's good that now this
is narrowed down to one individual
i think henry's right that he has to
have the opportunity to put his case
forward we don't know the detailed
circumstances here you know there's a
very strong premier fascia case
including evidence from two female mps
that they saw him as they described
watching porn but i don't know about you
i have received completely unwanted kind
of spam into whatsapp groups or twitter
dms
of
you know both male and female genitalia
completely took me by surprise horrific
if that is what happened to him then
perhaps he can be forgiven perhaps he
should be concentrating a little harder
in the house of commons but he does need
to be able to put that story forward the
reality though is that this story kind
of comes on top of just a whole series
of um
horrific allegations about mps but
conservative mps in particular there are
now four
who have lost the conservative whip
since the last general election as the
result of
accusations of sexual misconduct you
know that feels like a cultural problem
that spreads beyond simply what happened
in those moments on neil parrish's phone
and henry that passed the pressure even
more um on him with with colleagues
saying that there's a quote here that um
he's got to go and if he doesn't we've
got to get rid of him
it does although the mechanisms for
getting rid of an mp are rightly given
that the the sort of special role that
they have are very limited the
conservative party can withdraw the whip
which means that uh he will no longer
count as a conservative mp and if that
situation persists until the next
election he will not be able to stand
for his seat again as a conservative
which um will mean he probably ends up
leaving parliament but rightly the tory
party can't kick him out of the house of
commons because he was put there by his
constituents and there are limited means
by which constituents themselves can
recall him so a lot of these stories one
of the things that is quite frustrating
um both from a political sort of
management angle and indeed from a moral
angle is that there are
limited avenues by which people mps
especially who who do wrong can be
forced to quit especially by their
parties they can go independent but many
of them in fact i think nearly all of
them
tend to be determined to stick around
until the next election and there's
limited things that anybody can do about
that
and polly according to the daily
telegraph uh female tourism in
particular demanding that uh he's
expelled
from the the party but according to
their article again he's refusing to
quit
well you can understand why he wants the
opportunity for his case to be heard by
the parliamentary commissioner but of
course you know that has uh implications
for party management
and also you can understand how uh women
mps and caroline knox uh uh conservative
mp has been very outspoken about this
feel like there is this widespread
cultural problem in the conservative
party and when it comes to culture in an
organization essentially what you permit
you promote and so this this hesitation
feels i think to some women particularly
in the conservative party like like
tolerance like acceptance of this kind
of behavior if it was just a one-off
it'd be one thing but actually we know
this allegation came up at a meeting of
conservative the conservative
parliamentarians where woman after woman
after woman was able to tell stories
uh of of
unacceptable experiences they had had at
the hands of their fellow
parliamentarians their peers in the
party who were male so
that's why they want this to be dealt
with expeditiously my view to the point
that henry's just made is that that
recall right that constituents have
should be
much much more open people should be
able to uh
submit a recall petition frankly anytime
they feel like
not with a high threshold for the number
of signatories you need to get but you
shouldn't have to wait for these
sluggish voluntary procedures you
shouldn't have to wait for the
proceedings of our of of our criminal
justice system if if if constituents
of large numbers are furious with mp for
conduct like this they should be able to
say we want a new one yes the article
says that uh female tory mps as we've
been discussing
um
they are are furious at the way it has
been handled uh by the the party whips
um so not at all pleased with with how
has been handled and i think there's uh
who is it daisy cooper the deputy leader
of the liberal democrats said the prime
minister should tell mr parish to resign
immediately
do you think that that might follow that
might be the case henry that we we might
be hearing that the prime minister has
asked him to resign
uh it it might of course the prime
minister has no power to make him do it
i think the flip side of the sort of the
limited power that the tory party has to
kick any mp out of the house of commons
which is proper we should say you know
it wouldn't be right if if any party had
the ability to actually kick an mp out
but it does mean that boris johnson
could just withdraw the whip permanently
and never let him back in the
conservative party's internal
disciplinary procedures and its own
criteria for membership and the whip are
not subject to
the findings of a house of commons
commissioner so i think it's important
that whilst mr uh gets his
day in court as it were it's important
to remember that boris johnson doesn't
need to wait for catherine stone to take
action himself if he decides that this
behavior was unacceptable it is entirely
within his gift to make an example to
say this is completely unacceptable and
to withdraw the whip and say that
whatever happens mr parish will not
contest the next election as a
conservative mp now he might not choose
to do that he might choose to wait for
the parliamentary commission of
standards to report but he does have
that power and he will therefore be
accountable whether or not he does or
doesn't decide to use it yes and polly
it's uh yet another inquiry um that we
are faced with uh and i suppose
embarrassing for the prime minister
because he's also facing the inquiry a
different topic but but uh it speaks to
the um
the culture
i think it does
there is that sort of um
decadent decline and fall kind of vibe
that you get unfortunately from the
conservative government and that's
tragic because we really need a good
government uh james forcythe spectator
columnist was writing today about
you know that sense that the government
isn't capable of doing anything of
achieving anything because all of its
attention is focused on
these kind of inquiries and the scandals
and the party management and
you know i i it just feels like they are
absolutely missing in action
from the political agendas that matter
most like the cost of living crisis
which is you know pushing millions and
millions of our citizens to their
absolute financial limit and what's the
government doing it's like debating
porn you know it matters but it feels
like they have to get a grip
on the culture and the morality of their
own party if they want to be able to
govern and the problem with boris
johnson as a leader
is that he has is somebody who has got
away with all sorts of uh behavior you
know cheating on his partners
you know making slurs against people um
making jokes that you know others would
consider too blue or too inappropriate
um for for kind of parliamentary
standards so it's quite hard i think for
him to be the face of a cultural change
and the eyes moved on to the the problem
of mp's conduct overall um suggesting
that that victims
of uh various um
accusations
they are finding it difficult to to come
forward and actually bring them out in
into the open so almost bullied into to
submission and perhaps we're not hearing
the the half of the story henry
yeah the the stuff touched on in the eye
is actually really interesting because
it highlights a real difficulty and
tension when it comes to the
disciplinary procedures and the
investigative procedures which have been
put in place in the house of commons
because liam burn the story about liam
burn is basically that the icgs which is
the independent complaints body that's
been set up to investigate these issues
in parliament
when his staff complained to the icgs he
was told who they were and what their
complaints were now they were apparently
told wrongly as it turned out that they
were going to be they were going to be
anonymous so you now have this question
because on the one hand you want people
to feel safe and empowered to come
forward and make complaints against mps
who are quite powerful people but on the
other hand you
an mp will say and again icgs actually
applies to staff as well so the people
who are who have claims made against
them will say that they have the right
surely to
know the evidence that's being put to
them and the fact the matter is unless
you're some kind of omni pest if you are
given detailed accounts that you did x
to somebody in these circumstances you
will be able to work out who it is
that's making the complaint anyway so
there is a tension between making sure
that you've got adequate protection for
people so they can make complaints and
offering adequate recourse to justice
for people against whom complaints are
made who have the right to know the
evidence that's being made against them
and it's clear that the house of commons
hasn't yet got that right but i don't
think there's an easy way to reconcile
those two competing demands
polly are you surprised that westminster
staff are claiming to be afraid to to
report abuse
no i think it's in the nature of the
power relationship that you can very
often have in an mp's office an mp is
essentially
a very small employer perhaps employing
three or four people
um
they are
sort of protected from most systems of
accountability other than general
elections but because they've been put
there by the voters there isn't a board
you can report them to though there is
now this system there isn't there isn't
they haven't got a manager
they've only got the party so
the sense that you are basically at the
whim of this potentially brilliant
potentially awful boss
as a junior staffer is is i think really
problematic and the parties have an
important role to play there because
they can provide some mechanism support
and crucially for kind of exit for
people to be able to move on to other
jobs uh and and not feel like that kind
of precarity of trying to climb up the
political ladder and not wanting an mp
to be bad mouthing you that's something
that only the parties who have an
infrastructure of kind of other
political jobs have any hope of offering
in order to get around this kind of like
fundamental challenge that mps in the
end get to keep their job unless the
voters get rid of them
okay polly and henry for the moment
thank you